Welcome back to this next video. In this, we're going to be adding the second branch.
So we're going to be adding a little bit more functionality and learning how to
transition between different states in the state tree.
So we're back into our state tree here, and you can see that we have
our standard task. We've got root, idle, and then wanderabout.
So before we go on any further, I just want to sort of demonstrate
that you can see here what we've got is...
What's interesting is we've got this sort of down, so we can follow the path that this is going,
where previously we were working with the tree in the behavior tree,
where we just had to follow the path from the tree.
This is much more like conventional coding. We will follow a certain path.
By default, root is going to go into its child state and then into its child state again,
and you can see here that we have this little arrow at the end that says root.
That means if we select it, by default we have no transitions, but it will return
to the root as once we've finished this section of tasks.
Now we're going to change this. We're going to add in some transitions in a minute.
However, what is interesting is we have a number of different tasks here,
where previously we would create a sequence which would run these tasks one after the other.
The state tree works a little bit differently.
Now we have four tasks, change color, change speed, find random location, and move to location.
And by default these will all be kicked off. They will be kicked off in order,
but as you can see, so we're changing color, we're changing speed, finding random location,
then move to that location. They won't all stop together. So the first thing is
to move to a location we first have to finish the random location in order to
get the input variable. So they still go in order. However, the move to location
is a longer task and that will continue until it's reached the location or it's failed to get
out there. Now if we were to look at change color, we've got change color up here, you can
see that there is no finished task in here. And we don't actually require one. We only need
one finished task. And in this case we are using it on the move to location.
Now the interesting thing is you don't actually have to have...
If I was to remove these, so just connect, disconnect, finish task here, and run,
what we're going to see is the characters will basically finish off their first run
through the event. Then when they got to the end they're just stuck because they don't know
that the task is finished. We haven't told it, therefore it cannot transition out of it.
Now what is interesting though is it doesn't really matter where your finished task is.
So if I was to copy the finished task here and bung it after my change color like that,
now the thing about change color is that's going to happen almost instantaneously. So
that's going to be the first thing that happens on our list, change color. We're
telling it we finished the task successfully at that point. However, if I was to run,
what we would find now is after the characters have reached their destination,
they're going to transition again. So it's not instantly ending the task,
and it is still waiting for all of the tasks to finish, but it's marked as finished so that
it knows that it can transition out of this. So that's a bit of an interesting element.
You don't necessarily... here it's waiting for all of the paths to finish.
So you need a finished task somewhere in all of your tasks, and if you don't, by default,
it's not going to know what to do on a transition. Now let's look about
transitioning. Now the first thing that we want to do to transition is, since we are copying
our previous example, we want to check something. So we want to know when something specifically
happens, and we want to know when you are close to the character. And to do that,
we're going to use a global task. So I'm going to push plus here and search for check.
We should have a check for player. Now, as you can see, this is just a task like any other.
The only difference is that I'm running it as a global task. And this is quite nice because
it means we are now going to be able to access the variables that were bound within this
from anywhere. And if we were to look at this task, and we just find it,
check for player. See, it's very similar to what we created in our service. We're just grabbing
the NPC, which is of type Context, and the player character checking the distance. And if they're
close enough, we are going to save the player character to the player. So I'm going to compile
and save that. Now what we need to do next is, we want to create a new state. So under the root,
I'm going to add a new state in, a child state, and I'm going to call this draw
weapon. And this is going to be a transitional state. And from the draw weapon, what we'll have
is a couple of tasks in here. So again, I'm going to change the color, change color,
and I am going to add draw weapon. Okay, and again, we need to check. We need to make sure
that we've got the variable set up. Now, if I was to compile, you'll see that it's complaining
that draw weapon hasn't got to change a color for this. So again, in the parameters,
I'm going to add a new one called color, and is of a linear color. Now I'm going to set this
to a kind of pink, I think. Okay, then I'm going to connect that up to our parameter color,
and we're going to draw the weapon. Okay, and that's all of the tasks that I need in there.
Now, what we want to do is, at the moment, we're never going to get to this task,
because we're going to go that the Wonder About, when completed, is sending us back to root,
and the root is never going to get to draw weapon. So we're just going to continue
through this loop of Wonder About to root. So we want to create a transition.
So what we're going to do is come down to this purple transition section at the bottom,
and push plus. We're going to push plus twice, so we've got two different transitions.
Now, with the transition, what we have is a trigger, a transition to, and a condition.
So what I'm going to do is, I'm going to keep the standard trigger fine.
On state completed, go back to root. That's okay. I can leave that. I can just shut that down.
Now, the second one here, I want to check on tick at this point. So we've got a couple
of choices, but tick is a good one for us to go. So we've got tick, and I don't want to
transition to root. I want to transition to draw weapon. Now, we've also got a condition at the
bottom here. And I'm going to push plus on the condition. And the condition that I'm looking for
is, I want to check our global task. So the condition, I'm going to go plus,
I'm going to go object is valid. So here we go here. And we have object is valid.
And the object that we want to connect to is our global task. And we are looking for player,
which is an output of our global task. Check for player, player. There you go. So we're checking
to see if the player is valid. And if it is, on tick, it is going to send us to our draw
weapon, which is giving us the task of change color and draw weapon. Okay, so let's test this
out. We're back into the engine now and we got our characters. If I push play, as you can see,
everyone's going to start off by being yellow and just wandering around. And then when I get
close enough to one of them, it's going to log the player and they will draw their weapon.
And you can see here that all of the characters are now standing there,
and it's now stuck in that thing. You can see it for a second there. It jumps back into the
wanderer about as it's flashing yellow. But generally speaking, they're just standing there
with their weapons drawn. So let's prevent that jumping back into the wanderer about.
Now, if their weapons are drawn on the wanderer about, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
create a entry condition. So I'm going to push plus, and again, I'm going to look for object
is valid and the check for player, player. This time I'm going to invert it. So that's
going to take us to the, it's going to mean our only option here is to go to the draw weapon
state and let's try that out. So if I wander over to one of these characters, they turn and look at
me and they never go back into the wanderer about. Okay, so that's working well, but
let's jump on and see what's next. Right, so let's complete this entry. So we've got the
draw weapon that will send us back to root and then we'll come through back to the draw weapon state.
But let's add in an extra state here. Off of the root, add state. I'm going to call this
tack player. Now, one of the things I want to do while I'm still here is I'm going to give
these a sort of default color. And in order to change the default colors, I need to come down to
this theme section here. So we've got the default color. I'm going to add in a couple of others. So
I've got the idle color, which we're going to go in as yellow, and let's have our attack
color as pink. So that should do. Okay, and now what I can do is I can change this to our idle
color. It's a bit difficult to see that, but I'm just going to make that a bit of a darker
yellow. And we can change all of our attack ones to the attack color. Okay, so it's just
slightly easier to see what's going on at any one point. Okay, so with the attack color, I am
going to add in a couple more states. I'm going to add a chase color and the swing weapon.
So I will add another care one and drag that so it's under the attack player. I'm going to call
this chase player. Add state, add child state, and this is going to be swing weapon
within the attack player. So I'll have another entry condition, and this is going to be the same
entry condition as we had before. Object is valid, and we are checking the check for player.
So it's only going to be able to enter if we've already found the player. So let's start
off by setting up the chase player state. Now in this, we are going to need two different tasks.
The first one is going to be chase actor, and the second one is going to be update
speed based on distance. All this is going to do is it's going to chase the actor,
and it's going to change the speed of the actor based on how far away it is.
Now let's have a quick play with these. So in order to get this working, you can see that
we've got some inputs here. The context is fine. The actor should chase. Well, from this,
we can go check for player and get the player. However, we've got distance from player here.
We don't have the distance from player. So this is something we're going to need to get.
We could get this in a number of different ways. However, what I'm going to do is I'm going to
jump into the check for player blueprint, and we can see that we have this little
tick button here that if I push, it's going to open up directly.
And you can see that we have the distance here. So we have the distance from the player at this
point. So this is a good place that we can can grab it. And all I need to do to grab it
is promote this to a variable. I'm going to plug this into our chain,
and I'm going to set this to distance to layer. And again, if I want this to be visible from
outside so we can access it and use it as an input for a task, I have to change the category
to output. And that selects it in output. So now we can get the distance from the player
and the player from this task. So I save that, jump back into our chart,
and update speed based on distance from player to a drop down. Again, find the global task,
ST check for player and select distance from player. Okay, I'm going to change the colors
of these so they're all within the attack section. Now we are never going to get into
this chase player at this point, because the draw state is going to send us back to root,
and we're going to come back to the draw state each time. So what I want to do here
is when we've got to the draw state, the transition at the end, I want to add something in.
On state complete, I want to go to attack player. So that's going to take us down
into this loop here. Now, what I'm going to do on chase player is I'm going to add a transition,
so it doesn't go to root as well, just goes back to attack player. And I'm going to do
the same here for swing weapon. So once you've got into this loop for attack player,
there isn't much ability to get back to root. We're controlling the state at this point.
I hit compile, everything looks okay. Let's jump into the engine and test this out. So if I push
play, see we have our characters that are wandering around, but when I get close enough
to them, we'll draw his weapon and start to follow me. And then based on how far away I am,
they're going to run faster or slower. All I'm doing there is taking the distance from
the characters and then updating or reducing their speed accordingly.
Okay, so let's put in the final part. When they're close enough,
let's get them to attack the player. Okay, so let's jump back into the state tree.
So now we're always going back to the attack player here. So in order to specify between
chasing the player and swinging the weapon, we can use an entry condition on the chase player.
So if I push plus on an entry condition, and I want to do a float compare. So what we have
here is we want to check if something is greater than, and we are looking for, let's say,
100. And in the left we need the distance to player. So what's this doing is it's only
letting you into this condition if the distance to player is more than 100.
Okay, so that means that we would, if we are close, we're not going to go into the
chase player. We're going to go into the swing weapon. So in the swing weapon we want to add
one task. I'm going to push plus, and I'm going to search for attack, and select STT attack.
Now this all looks fine. The context is automatically connected up, so we should be okay.
However, I would like to make one change, and I want to demonstrate something.
Here we have STT attack, and that comes from the file name. Now you might not want to use
the file name. You might want to have some kind of different phrase so that you can sort of read
it better within the chart. Now if I push on the edit button, so that's that little pen
by the STT attack, and jump in, now under class settings you can see I have a blueprint
display name. If I change that to swing weapon and push compile, you'll now see the text just
says swing weapon. It also means when we're actually searching for it, we'll find this under
swing weapon, rather than the file name. So it's good to know that exists, because it
sometimes causes some kind of confusion when you're looking for specific tasks.
Right, so it's only going into the chase player if the player is over 100 centimeters away,
otherwise it's going to swing the weapon. Let's compile and try this out. You can now see
my character and they will chase me if I get further away, otherwise they'll surround me
and start trying to hit me. And with that, we've come to the end of the course.
So thank you for sticking with us. I hope you've gone through some of the exercises and
have a good understanding of how the AI, both the AI systems work. Thanks a lot. Bye.